notre invité politique ce matin c'est
bruno retailleau bonjour bon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sénateur de la
vendée président du groupe l'est
républicain ici au sénat on est ensemble
pendant un peu plus de vingt minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par votre presse quotidienne
régionale
ou est-ce france bonjour stéphane bern
est bonjour organes et on commence par
ce qui s'est passé hier dans votre parti
bruno retailleau le calendrier et la
méthode de christian jacob ont été
confortés on va en parler il y aura un
congrès le 25 septembre jean leonetti
travaille à un système de rassemblement
c'est ce que dit christian jacob
il rappelle néanmoins les candidats à la
responsabilité à trouver un accord s'il
n'y a pas d'accord il y aura un système
de rassemblement mis en place
désignation du candidat en novembre
est-ce que vous avez échoué finalement
hier à imposer la primaire de la droite
et du centre la primaire ouverte que
vous souhaitiez pour l'instant on a
réussi à se rassembler derrière cette
motion grosso modo le calendrier de
christian jacob que je trouve c'est vrai
trop trop repousser un je lui ai souvent
dit mais aussi on a mandaté jean
leonetti pour étudier les modalités
d'une primaire
ce que je veux dire sur le fond et en
prenant un peu de hauteur
c'est que ma famille politique vient de
gagner quatre élections territoriales et
nationales les multiples liens non les
sénatoriales les régionales et
départementales
ceux qui ont échoué c'est emmanuel
macron avec en marche et c'est marine le
pen avec le rassemblement national
c'est à dire que les deux pour
lesquelles ces élections était un fiasco
ce sont les deux qu'on voudrait nous
faire croire comme composant finalement
la mise en scène du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle mais les
français n'en veulent pas donc on a
notre responsabilité
et cette responsabilité elle est
importante elle exige de nous puisque
nous sommes les seuls les français ne
veulent pas ce face à face donc et nous
et nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir
porter une alternative
j'ai toujours pensé que puisque aucun
candidat naturel ne s'impose aujourd'hui
et des candidats à l'extérieur de l air
valérie pécresse xavier bertrand qui lui
est déjà déclarée
et puis à l'intérieur bien j'ai toujours
considéré que le départage à primaires
c'était une façon moderne
tout le monde s'est dit voilà il ya trop
peu de participation il ya trop
d'abstention parce que je propose c'est
le vote parce que dans une démocratie
moderne contient différents camps
personne ne s'impose
bah c'est le vote c'est le vote qui
départage les personnalités qui
départage les projets on peut pas vous
voir plus de participation et ne pas
vouloir que nos militants ou
sympathisants puissent participer mais
j'ai bien vu hier encore qu'on est assez
divisés sur la question des primaires
parce que pour beaucoup ils ont associé
la défaite de françois fillon à la
primaire c'est une erreur d'analysé
une grosse erreur d'analystes c'est
l'erreur que fait christian c'est
l'erreur que fait christian jacob
notamment pour mon papa je crois que
dans le parti politique c'est bien au
delà bien au delà je pense que c'est ce
que lui avait permis d'avoir un élan et
qui lui a permis ensuite malgré une
campagne et vous en souvenez qui avait
été très très difficile à cause des
affaires qu'il avait permis de faire les
20%
donc moi je veux qu'on se rassemble et
je pense que dès lors qu'il n'ya pas de
candidat naturel
l'unité on doit la rechercher dans une
compétition qu'ils soient apaisées j'ai
fait des propositions d'ailleurs sur les
modalités un scrutin à un tour
préférentiel c'est peu importe c'est de
la technique ça n'a pas été retenu je
n'y reviens à non je pense que dans les
modalités que prévoit par exemple il
nous l'a dit hier jean leonetti il
retient lui évidemment qu'une primaire
si elle doit avoir lieu doit avoir lieu
à un tour parce que c'est entre les deux
tours que les fractures les divisions se
sont avivées donc voila moi ce que je
verse une primaire fermée c'est ça
réservée aux seuls militants non moi il
faut une primaire ouverte
il faut vous là il freine primaires
ouvertes j'avais proposé moi par exemple
qu' on est par exemple et sympathisants
qu'ils puissent s'inscrire s'inscrit
dans un fichier avec une cotisation pour
qui une démarche bien plus volontaire
qu'elle ne l'était en 2016
mais je crois que si on n'a pas cette
compétition franche loyal je pense que
l'on va pas aboutir
il ya un énorme risque et je pense qu'il
ya pourtant une espérance qui s'élevait
chez les français et c'est nous qui
sommes porteurs de cet été cette
espérance 3km à kron or un très mauvais
bilan
les français veulent de l'or de la
sécurité nous
ce parti cette famille politique qui
incarne cette autorité
ils veulent aussi non plus comment
dirais-je la discrimination positive
le bac au rabais ils veulent la
méritocratie le mérite républicain
ils veulent aussi non plus la provision
le déclassement économique des français
me veulent la prospérité et nous nous
pouvons incarner cela vraiment il faut
se rassembler je pense et je lui ai
toujours dit voyez on parle beaucoup de
primaire d'ailleurs c'est mieux
puisqu'il ya un an j'étais seul à en
parler mais pour moi c'est une méthode
est en tout cas si on ne participe pas
ensemble à cette méthode là ce que je
crains c'est qu'on aura pas d' équipe de
france moi je veux une équipe de france
tout le monde veut une équipe de france
sauf que tout le monde voudrait être le
numéro 1 en équipe de france dont il
faut bien quand même un système ou alors
qu'on me propose une alternative
est-ce que l'alternative c'est les
sondages ça me fait rigoler quand on
voit ce que ça donne créée les sondages
récemment
est ce que c'est un conclave ou est ce
que c'est le père noël le miracle
république à bout
oui la part annoncé candidat qu'il tombe
du ciel que la candidate a annoncé
christian jacob au sondage
il y aura quand même un sondage chez les
républicains oui mis tout le monde à
coup bien sûr mais tout le monde a
compris tout le monde a compris
l'éclairage est qu'en réalité ils ne
venaient pas en compétition avec une
autre méthode mais le temps passe et le
temps presse et on ne t'en passer le
plus le temps passe et moi on maîtrise
notre calendrier bruno retailleau toutes
les propositions que vous n'aidez ok
vous les avez déjà fait il ya près d'un
an
c'est vrai la baule personne ne vous a
écouté comment est ce que vous expliquez
que que les républicains aient pu perdre
autant de temps est ce que tout ça c'est
c'est la réponse de christian jacob qui
vous évoquez la méthode père noël pour
christian jacob le père noël s'est
toujours françois baroin non je pense
que c'est quelque chose que je respecte
moi j'ai vécu ce traumatisme de 2017 et
je vois bien l'association que certains
peut faire entre la défaite et la
primaire mais je pense que c'est une
fausse analyse et je pense que dans le
monde moderne
les gens veulent participer les français
savent parfaitement que la clé de voûte
de nos institutions
les choix qu'ils commanderont leur
avenir et surtout l'avenir de leurs
enfants vous avez vu le sondage qui est
l'étude qui est sorti de doxa il ya
quelques jours
nous sommes à nouveau le peuple le plus
pessimiste d'europe
donc je crois que il faut pour cette
élection présidentielle qu'on la prépare
qu'on se met en ordre de bataille est
aujourd'hui la seule explication parce
qu'il ya un paradoxe quand même jamais
la france a été autant à droite
jamais on n'a eu autant de succès jamais
un bilan d'après de la prison république
n'a été aussi médiocre et pour autant il
est assez haut dans les sondages mails
macron c'est tout simplement qu'on n'est
pas en ordre de bataille
c'est un verseau l'enfer à seulement que
bien sûr donc moi j'appelle j'appelle
cette cette méthode j'appelle
sereinement bien sûr il faut se
rassembler je donne raison d'ailleurs à
christian jacob
il va absolument le rassemblement c'est
normal il a quand même perdu beaucoup de
temps oui non mais mais c'est pas moi
mais le tir est ce qu'il n'est pas en
train un peu d'organiser une course à la
lenteur christian jacob de repousser de
repousser en tout cas je pense que peu
plus le temps passera plus celui qui en
sera le bénéficiaire c'est xavier
bertrand puisque son pari précisément
c'est ça c'est de partir plus vite de
jouer le lièvre est d'arriver à
s'installer dans les sondages vient se
présenter comme le candidat qui
potentiellement patients dans la
symbolique du vin pour son nom je pense
quand même que mais je pense que si vous
voulez rassembler les français
faut s'y rassembler sa propre famille
politique certes xavier a quitté l r je
le considère toujours de notre famille
politique au sens large
mais si vous voulez vraiment rassembler
les français il faut faire cet effort de
rassemblement
et si on doit avoir une règle commune il
faut que chacun y participe
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
proposer une primaire ouverte à un tour
qui la parlent de 2-2-2 affrontements
très violents entre le premier et le
deuxième tour c'est pour ça que je
propose une primaire la plus ouverte
possible parce que si on a une primaire
très très ouverte il sera très très
difficile pour ceux qui n'en seront pas
de justifier leur non participation ils
se mettront en quelque sorte un peu hors
jeu
difficile ici ne participent à la
primaire il accroche ou valérie pécresse
qui s'appelle social andorre le pks pour
la tribune avec la primaire or xavier
bertrand lui l'a redit hier au 20 heures
de tf1 non je ne participerai pas la
pucelle à droite et mais est-ce qu'elle
a un sens cette primaire sans le laver
bertrand ou est ce que vous dites oui
alain sens mais lui se met hors-jeu il
pourra pas être notre quand je pense si
je pense qu'une primaire très très
ouverte pourrait rallier sans doute y
compris j'espère que vous avez bertrand
tout cas c'est le pari que je fais j'ai
commencé vous savez il ya quelques jours
j'ai vu tous les candidats de michel
barnier et xavier bertrand laurent
wauquiez valérie pécresse
il faut faire ce travail moi je veux
être un facteur de rassemblement je suis
un président de groupe
dans mon groupe il y en a qui ont une
sensibilité proche des uns ou des autres
je veux d'abord préserver l'unité du
groupe parce que le rôle du sénat
il est fondamental c'est le seul pôle
comment dirais-je de contre-pouvoir pour
la démocratie c'est fondamental
un contre-pouvoir dieu sait si le
pouvoir mc rogne 1 et les traits
jupitérien donc je pense qu'il faut
préserver cela mais je serai un facteur
d'unité mais ça vous croyez encore au
fait que xavier bertrand peut participer
à cette primaire
si pour vous c'est saïd sylla primaire
est suffisamment ouvert ça lui sera très
très difficile de rester en dehors c'est
ce que je crois pour le moment force est
de constater que compte tenu du
calendrier on n'en prend pas vraiment
chemin moi je le regrette j'essaie de
préserver au maximum notre unité
je le ferai jusqu'au bout c'est un peu
le signal que vous avez voulu envoyer
avec cette tribune signée avec laurent
wauquiez et hervé morin et valérie
pécresse de dire finalement xavier
bertrand est isolé il est un peu hors
jeu comme vous dites s'ils ne
participent à cette prime à moi cette
c'est le 26 mars que j'avais proposé
aussi bien leur wauquiez aller pécresse
et j'en avais parlé lors d'un déjeuner à
1 christian jacob puis je vais dit
écoutez on va on laisse passer les
régionales je comprends parfaitement
mais aussitôt après il y aura une prise
de position publique parce que c'est
important
il faut trouver un moyen je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de français qui comptent sur
nous faut pas les décevoir
il faut se rassembler et il faut que
chacun comprenne notre responsabilité
mais un engagement c'est que quoi qu'il
arrive il faudra néanmoins qu'ils en
aient un seul un seul parce que sinon ça
sera l'élimination
il faudra se regrouper et il faudra de
toutes nos forces
quel qu'il soit il faudra l'aider vous
risquer l'élimination comme vous dites
il ya plusieurs candidats à la
présidentielle à droite pour l'année
prochaine
mais avant ça est ce que les
républicains risque l'implosion dans
cette histoire elles sont repartis peu
se désagréger il fait de ses dissensions
internes
non parce que quand je vous parlais des
municipales des sénatoriales des
régionales et départementales c'est
fondamental de garder une force certes
les partis n'ont pas la même force n'ont
plus la même force que autrefois parce
que on est dans une société hyper
individualisé parce que je pense qu'il
faut qu'on soit capable de comment
dirais-je de développer d'autres modes
d'appartenance par exemple des
communautés numériques c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire aussi dans le cadre de
forces républicaines donc les parties
doivent se renouveler
mais un parti c'est néanmoins une force
on le voit bien à ces élections parce
que les militants parce que le fait de
réfléchir à un certain nombre de
questions parce que la constitution
l'article 4 voilà c'est que donne au
parti politique c'est la première
constitution 2d république française qui
a reconnu les partis politiques un rôle
pour l'expression du suffrage universel
qui est important mais on doit se
renouveler et je pense qu'on doit faire
participer au delà même nos militants on
a 75 mille militants c'est beaucoup par
rapport à d'autres parties c'est une
vraie force et je veux les saluer mais
si ils veulent gagner et pour gagner il
faut s'y agréger nos sympathisants nos
électeurs est-ce qu'il faut forcément un
candidat issu des républicains est ce
que si cette primaire a lieu vous dites
les républicains ne pourront pas
soutenir les aviez bertrand parce que
lui quand on l'entend il est
complètement en dehors des républicains
est visiblement il cherche pas trop à
faire un pas vers vous il dit moi j'ai
quitté le parti politique c'est pas pour
entrer dans une logique qui est la leur
mais ce que je pense ou un c'est que
cette élection présidentielle est
fondamental fondamentale je pense qu'il
ya cet espoir j'en ai déjà parlé mais
très franchement on peut relever le défi
on ne peut le faire que si ce n'est pas
une chevauchée solitaire
on a vu ce qu'était une chevauchée
solitaire avec mails macron ça mène à
rien finalement ça une pluie c'est dans
une semaine dans une chevauchée
solitaire à l'heure actuelle pour
l'instant il dit dans cette démarche
solitaire il faudra que tôt ou tard
moi je ne préfère bien sûr que le
candidat que on soutiendra à l'élection
présidentielle porte la marque de notre
famille politique gaulliste
bien sûr je le préfère une sorte de
patriotisme employés mais je ne suis pas
non plus totalement obtus et si une
autre famille politique au sens très
large se range derrière un candidat qui
n'est pas statique est bien moi je
travaillais je pense qu'il faut tourner
la page du quinquennat macron vous
l'avez rencontré xavier bertrand la
semaine dernière vous l'avez dit est ce
qu'il vous a proposé de le rejoindre
alors écoutez je le canton quand on
commence à discuter en tête à tête
la première condition c'est la
confidentialité
sinon on n'a pas franchement pas non
sinon on n'a pas la même franchise
voilà donc je les ai rencontrés c'est
discuter avec eux et tous faire une
équipe
chacun veut bien sûr y compris moi
peut-être d'ailleurs est ce premier
league et pourquoi peut-être parce que
xavier bertrand lui la semaine le mérite
d'être clair il dit moi je suis candidat
à la présidentielle est ce que vous vous
le dit aussi clairement ce n'est pas un
mérite non il il a pris ce pari de
partir seul
moi j'en appelle au collectif de toute
façon ni lui ni aucun autre
aucun m'entendais bien parce que le
déficit sera rude quand même de faire
turbuler fameux face à face bastille a
pas de collectif
ça sera la défaite mais ce que vous
dites clairement oui moi aussi j'ai
envie d'être candidat à la présidence et
bien il ya d'abord la question des
primaires pour moi que j'ai toujours mis
dans mon agenda puisque mon analyse
c'est que sansan les primaires c'est
compliqué dont sept candidats aux
primaires donc à la présidentielle voilà
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit
nemo sur la droite parce que vous dites
depuis des mois vous avez même écrit un
livre à ce sujet que la reconstruction
de la droite à doit passer par le projet
doit passer par les idées est ce
qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois les
querelles d'ego et les questions de
personnes ne sont pas en train de mettre
ce projet au second plan est de le
rendre inaudible mais justement je pense
qu'une méthode de départage c'est une
façon de départager des projets je pense
que on doit converger pour essayer
d'avoir des réponses sur les deux
grandes angoisses française les deux
grandes angoisses française c'est un le
déclassement économique et social le
fait que aujourd'hui les parents
craignent pour l'avenir de leurs enfants
il ya le sentiment qui n'est pas un
sentiment c'est réel de
l'appauvrissement des français on a
perdu des milliers d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat et de niveau de vie par rapport
aux allemands depuis 20 ans plus de 5000
euros
c'est la chute collective le déclin 78%
des français le pensent
et puis il ya une autre angoisse l'autre
angoisse c'est la dépossession
culturelles identitaires le fait que
submergé par une immigration immigration
qui devenu incontrôlé on perde notre
mode de vie notre culture qu'on se
retrouve en quelque sorte étrangers chez
soi eh bien je pense que la question du
niveau de vie qui passe par le travail
je pense que si on veut créer plus de
richesse
il faudra travailler plus d'où par
exemple la question de déduit départ de
l'âge de la retraite soit on s'appauvrit
collectivement soit on appauvrit nos
jeunes qui auront une charge énorme à
supporter pour payer les retraites soit
on appauvrit les retraités ou soit on
travaille plus collectivement ont créé
plusieurs richesses et du coup on a du
pouvoir d'achat et puis il ya l'enjeu
culturel mois au bout du bout je pense
que la politique et ça souvent été
l'erreur de la droite cds de réduire la
la politique à l'économie à la seule
économie à la gestion économie non la
politique c'est aussi l'immatériel c'est
aussi la culture
aujourd'hui tous les peuples d'europe
sont tenaillés par des questions
existentielles sur leur mode de vie
parce que y'a l'islamisme parce que dès
cette immigration qui est de moins en
moins contrôlé et qui sera de plus en
plus pressante
compte tenu du boom démographique de
l'afrique donc je crois que il ya ces
questions là qu'il faut
dhr en main il faut reprendre le
contrôle ce que n'a pas fait mal macron
émane macron nous sommes le seul pays
vous rendez compte avoir élargi depuis
cinq ans par exemple le regroupement
familial le désordre l'insécurité j'ai
constaté quand j'ai fait les
sénatoriales que des maires de communes
chez moi en vendée d'un peu plus de 1000
habitants c'est qu'ils paient en caméras
de vidéoprotection c'est un phénomène et
même ce week-end dans sa certain nombre
de villes il ya eu des affrontements
entre des policiers et des bandes de
jeunes
et qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya un
problème de laxisme judiciaire c'est pas
un problème d'effectifs de police c'est
d'abord un problème de réponse
judiciaire
est ce qu'on aura le courage oui ou non
de dire aux français ce que nous pensons
à trop souvent la droite a rasé les murs
parce que elle était si j'ose dire
tétanisés par les injonctions de la
gauche bien le moment est venu de
redresser la tête vase et les murs et ça
veut dire laisser le champ libre au
rassemblement national peut bien sûr
mais bien sûr on a quitté nos
convictions pour plaire pour répondre
aux journalistes sur les plateaux de
télévision
voilà dans le bon sens dans le sens du
politiquement correct pour faire plaisir
à un certain nombre de personnalités du
microcosme et on a abandonné l'idée de
la patrie l'idée du fait de pouvoir
contrôler les frontières on a vu
regarder le virus les pays qui s'en
sortent le mieux sont les pays qui ont
tenu leurs frontières
la frontière c'est pas quelque chose de
négatif dans une maison vous avez des
murs là vous protège vous avez une porte
aussi avec une entrée je suis pas pour
une immigration zéro je suis pour que
l'on reprenne le contrôle pour le peuple
français
parce que cette grande question est sans
doute depuis 40 ans celle qui a le plus
profondément bouleversé notre société et
or c'est la question qui a été écarté de
la délibération du peuple français c'est
incroyable c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est un grand philosophe plutôt d'heure
qui n'est pas de ma sensibilité
politique quai marcel gauchet autre
sujet vous venez parler de la frontière
tenir la frontière du virus
on voit qu'il ya trois régions dans
lesquelles le verrions delta devient
majoritaire
le premier ministre a écrit aux
présidents de groupes parlementaires la
semaine dernière en leur demandant leur
avis sur un centre de points par rapport
à la vaccination obligatoire l'extension
du du pass sanitaires et le
l'instauration ou par le renforcement
des processus de de quarantaine
d'isolement quel a été votre réponse
vous deviez ils répondront hier si je me
suis je suis je ne m'abuse notamment sur
le vague de la vaccination obligatoire
quelle est la position votre position
officielle sur ces questions elle n'a
pas varié
simplement j'ai dit au premier ministre
arrêtons de considérer que chaque vague
doit être la der des ders chaque fois on
dit voilà on a on a gagné un pari
et puis ensuite on s'en doute auront
droit aux narines 4 il ya bien sûr
vraisemblablement sais je ne sais pas je
suis pas épidémiologie suffit conseillés
par des gens qui sont épidémiologique
parce que je pense que quand on est un
homme politique il faut il faut aussi
avoir des appuis des conseils mois sur
la vaccination des personnels soignants
je suis très clair puisque début
décembre mails macron 12 invite à
déjeuner à l'elysée avec les brise en
deux groupes sur la stratégie vaccinale
et je lui ai dit il faut en priorité
vacciner les fragiles il faut en
priorité
l'obligation pour le personnel soignant
de la vaccination les geôles de la
paille aux gens j'ai par exemple les
enseignants de ce dossier je pense que
là ça pose un problème parce que dès
lors que vous posez une obligation
vous devez voir si vous avez une
sanction qui puisse vous permettre de
faire respecter l'obligation ce qui est
quand même compliquée deuxième élément
je pense que sur le pass vaccinale je ne
suis pas pour l'open bar pour par
exemple les étrangers passent des tests
gratuits de lanfranc c'est pas possible
on doit les faire payer
et par exemple partir d'aujourd'hui pour
les français pour les français je pense
que on devrait avoir de test gratuit que
sur prescription médicale ça encouragera
là aussi la vaccination mais la
vaccination c'est ce que j'ai dit au
premier ministre
ça n'est pas là cela on se trompe parce
que on ne parviendra pas à l'immunité
collective des 90% avant de longs mois
ça veut dire qu'il ya l'autre pan
l'autre arme qu'on a délaissé en france
tracez séquence est dépisté isolé je
veux et il faut des hôtels quarantaine
pour des gens qui seront infectés par le
delta il faut vraiment les isolés
pendant 14 jours on les paiera déjà trop
tard mes tracés par l'autre pas par leur
être au traçage comme font les japonais
ont peu en dessous de 5000 cas on peut
le faire
est-ce qu'on le fait vraiment il faut
séquences et on est un élève médiocre
sur le nombre de séquençages le
séquençage saison une progression les
dans la région des pays de la loire
s'est il ya que les deux chu public qui
sait qu'en ce mois je veux que lié aussi
les labos privés ont fait la même erreur
qu'on a fait il ya un an sur les tests
j'ai fait deux autres propositions au
premier ministre première proposition
que on tire les leçons puisque c'est
l'hôpital qui a été le niveau de
pilotage et j'ose dire des confinement
est bien conforme plusieurs et animateur
est ce que vous savez l'an dernier le
décret pour qu'ils calculent qu'ils
imposent le cursus le numerus clausus
pour les élèves les inters de médecine
qui vont faire la réanimation
on est passé de 72 à 74 fort il ya déjà
un manque de 329 réanimateurs en france
et dans les 53 cents vont partir donc
n'attendons pas essayons là aussi de
débloquer le numerus clausus première
proposition autre proposition les écoles
pourraient devenir des lieux juste un an
de contamination je propose qu'on rende
obligatoire
les capteurs de co2 dans les écoles
c'est ce qui permet ça coûte moins de
100 euros
voilà on équipes toutes les classes des
primaires des collèges et des lycées
et quand ça devient rouge quand il ya un
petit signal sonore on ouvre justement
les fenêtres on aère parce que on sait
désormais avec des études scientifiques
que la propagation du virus se fait par
les aérosols c'est ça qu'il faut prévoir
moi j'attends du premier ministre une
attitude qui soit vraiment anticipatrice
enfin essayons ne pas avoir toujours une
bière de retrait vis-à-vis ce foutu
virus
référendum cuma puisque jean castex a
annoncé hier l'abandon du processus
législatif sur ce référendum climat
rejetant la faute sur le sénat qui n'a
pas voté conforme avec les députés lundi
soir qu'est ce que vous pensez traire le
scénario est écrit est ce que vous
pensez un seul instant kebbell bakr on
voulait faire un référendum à quelques
mois des présidentielles sachant qu'un
référendum souvent les français
répondent non pas la question mais celui
qui pose la question
non c'était un cadeau qu'est ce que vous
dites que ça les arrange bien ce
fabuleux c'est bien sûr c'est pour ça
qu'il n'a pas bougé ils ont bloqué sur
le terme de garantir le mot garantir a
été dénoncée par le conseil d'état c'est
pas le le sénat qui a voulu faire un
coup politique ces mails macron qui a
fait un coup de com' vis-à-vis de la
convention citoyenne qui l'a très mal
notée en est on le comprend d'ailleurs
vis-à-vis de ses actions pour le pour le
climat et le conseil d'état avait dit
attention il ya d'énormes inconvénients
et pour cela le sénat heureusement a
fait obstacle pourquoi pour deux raisons
la première c'est que le terme de
garanties c'était inoculé dans notre loi
fondamentale la constitution
le virus de la décroissance pour nos
entrepreneurs pour les français qui n'en
veulent pas et serait accéléré
l'appauvrissement de la france c'est pas
l'écologie
nous souhaitons cette écologie
autoritaire punitive la deuxième raison
c'était que le terme de garanties
faisait qu' on aurait une jurisprudence
on aurait des juges qui se serait
prononcé
mais alors sur des décisions parfois
contradictoires et on laissait le
pouvoir justement au juge moi je suis
législateur c'est au législateur de
faire la loi et non pas aux magistrats
donc c'est ce sont ces deux raisons qui
nous ont amenés à bloquer si le
gouvernement voulait vraiment référendum
enfin le président de république il
aurait par exemple le mot agir favorise
préserve on a un vocabulaire extrêmement
riche c'est pour ça que du gouvernement
contre la majorité à brielles attali les
justes et il est allé jusqu'à dire que
vous étiez climat tous les petits mais
écoutez un gouvernement qui était le
plus condamné par la cour de justice de
l'ordre par le conseil d'état par
comment diriger magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire pour ses actions non efficace
vis à vis le climat n'a pas de soins
donnés mail macron c'est en quatre ans
quatre ministres de l'ecologie comment
voulez vous que l'on puisse construire
une politique de long terme
en changeant deux ministres pratiquement
tous les ans non il a fermé par exemple
fessenheim
savez-vous qu'une centrale nucléaire que
l'on ferme ce sera nécessairement des
importations notamment de gaz émission
de serre puisque on va avoir une
importation d'une énergie qui vient qui
n'est pas décarbonés et par rapport à
une centrale à gaz une centrale
nucléaire rejette quarante cinq fois
moins de co2 par kilo watt par rapport à
cette centrale
justement à gaz donc là aussi si on veut
vraiment engager la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
il faut être sérieux et on sait que en
d'écart bonne en électricité qui est la
grande énergie du 20e siècle
alors on luttera vraiment contre le
réchauffement climatique d'ailleurs les
gaz à effet de serre en france c'est 1%
-2 1% du total mondial et on va terminer
stéphane avec la réforme des retraites
et oui maintenant à quoi a reçu hier les
partenaires sociaux pour parler retraite
quels autres conseils au président en la
matière a fouillé les maintenant où il
vaut mieux attendre que la
présidentielle soit pas ses fans
courageux dont c'est la faute de quoi j
permettent aux fouilles attendant nous
français dans la réputée même françois
hollande tous les pressions de
république depuis edouard balladur qui
était dans une situation certes de
cohabitation mais tous ont assumé une
réforme des retraites pourquoi l'anti
assumer y compris d'ailleurs françois
hollande avec la réforme touraine sur la
durée de cotisation tout simplement
parce que c'est un patrimoine commun
c'est la sécurité sociale et c'est
important on a un régime par répartition
auquel les français tiennent
particulièrement si je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure on n'augmente pas et on ne
recule pas la durée notamment l'âge
légal de départ
jusqu'où pour vous 64 sur 50 dans un
premier temps 64 ans bien sûr est le
problème si on n'augmente pas c'est un
an baissera les pensions donc on
atteindra le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités d'achat des retraités
en rejettera sur l'épaule des jeunes
générations une charge qui sera
insupportable et enfin on traite ce
problème français le premier français
est qu' on ne travaille pas suffisamment
au cours d'une année ou au cours d'une
vie voilà non pas parce que les français
sont paresseux c'est parce que les
jeunes ont du mal par exemple à
travailler et âme à trouver du travail
lorsqu'il se par exemple ils passent
leurs études leur diplôme
c'est un problème d'accès au marché du
travail et on part plus tôt à la
retraite
si on ne traite pas ce sujet là si on
n'augmente pas ce qu'on appelle le taux
d'emploi la proportion de français en
âge de travailler qui travaillent
effectivement on s'appauvrira et bien
l'expérience par exemple de la dernière
réforme de 2010 derrick bird dessous et
monsieur sarkozy est bien deux ans de
plus et le taux d'emploi a aussi
augmenté
donc ça crée un effet de richesse et
magma cran a raison de dire que c'est la
mère de toutes les réformes
sera-t-il le réformateur qu'il voudrait
être pour l'instant il ne l'a pas été il
pourrait le devenir
s'il assumait si j'ose dire une réforme
courageuse qui permettent justement
tester ses fruits la rentrée
parlementaire de septembre pour vous
d'octobre enfin le plus rapidement
possible puisque on a un déficit je vous
le rappelle abyssal de la sécurité
sociale
plus de 30 milliards 32 milliards l'an
passé une trentaine de milliards cette
année
le système va finir par exploser sauvera
ton évolution
si demain vous aussi à la rentrée vont
présenter une réforme des retraites qui
repousse l'âge à 64 ans les républicains
sont quasiment chaque année puisqu'on
fait cette proposition dans le plfss
d'année en année merci beaucoup merci au
détail aussi la var était notre invité
au regard la une de ouest france ce
matin c'est le bac tous les résultats
dans l'ouest par département merci
stéphane et merci encore bruno
retailleau
[Musique]